e eu acho que o pessoal de quem fala
andar que sejam muito bem vindos a mais
um ele o mestre pessoal nós vamos ver
erros de gravação de microblog jogo
gostoso para que o fisco pico durante o
big three chuveiro é alvo também entrou
eu enganei me fez ver se cantar a música
pop também mudança também há militares
quando estava em cima de mim e quase
caindo e vocês vão ver isso neste dia e
também eu acho que tem um conteúdo
engraçado porque normalmente quando o
youtube faz vídeo e sim é muito nova não
corta porque é isso que tento fazer o
que eu digo assim uma coisa podre corpo
quando ninguém quando começa a viajar
muito e é é um corta estudo então há
muita coisa que vocês não vêem e pelos
vistos nossa música estados do país o
força que nós vamos dar a portugal caso
do parto portugal helmand não perdeu
nenhum jogo em 2002 mas vocês viram aqui
o ronaldo afirmou que o ponto pedro
livre joga muito muito obrigada também
tudo que só está a mandar vídeos para o
instagram a cantar música muito obrigada
que insistiu muito obrigada a investir
life beijo no coração e já que estamos a
falar em mundial pessoal quero
apresentar aqui uma coisa pra vocês que
é um jogo muito importante mas não é o
fim sendo olha vou ligar aqui mas o
pessoal e ball 2 e para quem não tinha
sua moeda ou 2 é um jogo para o nosso
cimatti phone e android e oeste
o fórum é um jogo de futebol muito
viciante sério é muito eficiente é como
se fosse um pingue pongue quando os
jogadores duas balizas vocês podem jogar
contra todo mundo e este ano dentro da
simplicidade tem muita complexidade
porque têm poder sustentar que tem muita
coisa e muito obrigado por patrocinar
nóis é bom dois é porque nunca fomento
público papão até mesmo falar um pouco
do jogo só pra vocês perceberam quem é
como se joga futebol é 11 contra 11 de
qualquer país desde que estejam online e
o objetivo do jogo é marcar golos na
baliza do adversário longe mas pra isso
você tem que ir para o vosso bonequinho
tipo a figura que as escolheram e por
isso vocês têm várias figuras de você
vota têm voz e camisola tem tenha outros
que dão poder o instituto está poderes
da aspirina aponta apenas 11 cidades a
mudar muita coisa tão absurda que vocês
vão dançando com as postagens também
fica mais forte e para além disso
enquanto vocês estão as garotas também
podem usar superpoderes tipo aumentar a
burrice do adversário com o usuário
adversário que o cara tipo de são do
site plano em frente e para trás para
além disso também podem abrir busters
que sai carlos nesses caras vocês podem
ganhar novos personagem também respeito
não podem
teremos que sair assim como explodia
também muita coisa grave já que tem loja
tem vivendi tem vossa equipa vocês podem
fazer a nossa equipa de futebol é com
vocês podem vir olha só o meu personagem
está contaminada tem que passar de 100
ovos têm com botas sob o fogo da lava
com a sua vez vão ganhando vão subindo
no ranking vão lutar contra pessoas mais
fortes e eu inclusive perco muitas vezes
é porque nível porém já está muito
difícil mas é esse pessoal é bom dois
percursos gostem ocorrendo mesmo muito
sério aquele partido sério levantar em
inscrição vocês podem baixar e agora
vamos lá então para os nossos blue
perceber erros de gravação da paróquia e
joga pessoas por lá
[Música]
eu tô com deus a isabel eu jogar gostoso
tchauu texto da costa louco cuidado ao
que parece preparado
bom aí eles dizem que é difícil eu
poderia ganhar mais que o ronaldo melhor
do mundo dá pra acreditar num sonho da
aplicação da toxina os gaúchos em
ela joga o patrício na baliza nada vai
entrar com este futebol o aluno vai ter
que parar agora novas caras em primeiro
lugar mesmo a madrid leva eu deixa que
eu deixo ele vai por martinho com este
futebol no mundo vai ter que parar e vai
por martin eo jovem banda mesmo dia
acho que as pessoas vão fazer de tudo
pra cachorro ficou caixa
[Música]
eles dizem que é difícil bond ao ganhar
a não ser assim vai perder e cruiser
banheirinho municipais item moça bola
com querer gonçalo lo e cuidar do que
esses efeitos vão fazer de tudo para
preparar o pão eo arroz com feito no
caminho e encheu jogão ele jô
jogamos um amistoso
[Música]
a dona do modelo
ai ai chama mais a atenção não só por
causa do tipo de gente para o tempo nem
precisa saber se poderei contar o spray
e luiz navarro manda fumar
[Música]
o show vai embora
agora vou voltar a gravar
josé que mora sozinho vai à linha de
fundo para a ação
[Música]
lady gaga voltou a cair
acho que chuva x aproveitar a ida
acho que eu sei que deus as maiores
perdas ontem de manhã